joining us from the golf channel is
Brandel Chamblee how are you Brandel
terrific I'm just standing out here on
the grounds watching the log jam at the
top leaderboard it is how is the Golf
Course playing Randall I know that's a
mock my macro question but it's
beautiful weather and it does not appear
to be any wind as well why is it playing
ethical well the you know they have any
sub areas out here so they drive the
golf course up quite a bit from the
moisture that they had on Wednesday so
of course was drier and everybody
expected yesterday almost played to
scoring as your average of 74 yesterday
and it's almost playing a scoring
average of 75 today thus far so that's
it in a nutshell
wind wind firm greens mm-hmm and that's
it
so how do you are you surprised to see
the way it's all played out yeah I guess
the most surprising thing at this point
is Jordan speith shooting 40 on the
front nine you know he hasn't been here
20 years or anything that his first time
he's played nine holes without a birdie
made double it first he got up and hit
it
I don't know 60 yards right of the
fairway and then hit it barely got it
out and made double and then it had way
left at 1 just hit it all over the golf
course
didn't make any putts you know there's
eight guys right now tied for the lead
Matt Kuchar is at the top he quietly had
one of the best years in the major
championships in the last four or five
years last year he finished fourth the
Masters he was 16th at the US Open
obviously second at the Open
Championships stunned by speeds and then
ninth the PGA so you know he's got he
comes in here with the best form he's
ever had in his career and what you have
to do it again is be able to work it
left to right right to left you have to
be able to work at both directions and
Matt Kuchar has a great ability to do
that and because the greens are so firm
right now it's turned into a bit of a
scrambling contest and he's fabulous at
using the bounce on really firm
conditions well in the in the middle of
our are saying hello to each other Marc
Leishman no completed a birdie birdie
open to his round today and he's 4-under
par he's the only guy that's that's at
that mark right now well tell me about
his game and how he might be able to put
something together today to take a lead
over the weekend first of all it's I
mean if he goes
ah win it would be be history he's
playing alongside Tiger Woods nobody the
Tiger Woods has ever played with has won
the Masters and when you think about it
he's been paired with nothing but the
best players Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday
so getting inside his world is chaotic
so I took my cap to him for the type of
golf he's playing but having said that I
mean Leishman is a throwback to a sort
of a Bruce Lipsky if you're a golf nut
that's a guy who used to eat these big
cuts I didn't practice and made golf
look really really simple Marc Leishman
an era when everybody's talking about
science and everybody's going to the gym
he doesn't go to the gym he says he mows
his lawn for exercise and he just hits
these big high cuts everywhere he makes
the game look really simple but sooner
or later he's got to hit a draw on one
of these you know there's seven or eight
draw holes out there having a limited
shape shot off at the tee sooner or
later I would think would catch up with
him at Augusta Brandel Chamblee joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show take me
in your mind as you were watching Sergio
on 15 Thursday well we we always say
that the when you lay up at 15 it is the
hardest third shot in the world of golf
and went the whole location on sort of
the front right you know there were a
couple things going to my mind one
Sergio has changed golf balls so it
looked to me like you know who knows
maybe maybe he wasn't used to the spin
of that golf ball because he kept
throwing it up there and spinning it
back throwing up there spinning it back
now I know it's a it's a it's a tough
shot
but we saw jordan Spieth come in there a
little bit later and hit it a foot we
saw Dustin Johnson come in there and hit
it a foot controlling the spin so to hit
the same shot over and over and over
well I don't think I've ever seen to a
pro do anything like that not there I've
seen him meltdown at the at the 12th
hole and I've seen one or two balls in
on the 15th but never five yeah I mean
to see when he said it's the first time
he's ever done anything like that where
he didn't hit a bad shot he said he
thought he hit a great shot each time
what he said yeah I mean that's to a pro
speak for you no I'm trying to put salve
on this wound
I mean I'm absolutely positive he didn't
hit any of those shots the way he wanted
to
but you know I mean that's the way you
speak when you're a tour pro you have to
sort of you know you have to believe the
good stuff and try to find a good stuff
and talk to yourself but he still got a
chance to go out there make a cut
because the Golf Course is playing so
difficult what's the worst hole you've
had your playing career well one year I
heard about Seve Ballesteros making a
ten on a hole we were at dinner Saturday
night and we were all joking about Savi
making a 10 on the hole I think I said
something along the lines how do you
make a 10 on a hole the next day I made
a 10 on a hole yeah and I thought you
know what that's the golf gods just
totally screwing with me I laughed we
were joking around and you can't make a
tan on a hole I can't even remember how
many you know I'd left it in a hazard or
left it in a has or had a drop on the
bank I didn't even know what I made now
the worst part of it was I was playing
with a guy who was leading the
tournament so they showed every one of
my shots on TV and my parents had to
watch them so yes somewhere there exists
me making a ten on a hole on TV which
course was this again this was at TPC
Avenel the old Kemper open my rookie
year on tour so I think I remember
looking in the camera and asked my mom
to send more money Brandel Chamblee here
on the Masters report from Augusta
brought to you by our friends at
Callaway okay so is there rain coming I
mean is are the players looking for a
little bit of moisture help here it's
supposed to rain a little bit Saturday
but I don't think the forecast is is
ominous really I think it's supposed to
rain a little bit supposed to be
absolutely spectacular on Sunday but
right now it's it's it's warm
you know it's 74 75 degrees mmm you know
it's dry I'm sure the Golf Course is
playing you know rock hard fast so it's
gonna be really tough golf course today
but I expect you know by the end of the
day you know Rory's going to be right
there
jordan Spieth I think we'll make a few
birdies on the back nine we we have had
an unprecedented build-up for this
masters because there's so many great
names playing good and I I don't I don't
think we're gonna be disappointed come
Sunday night yeah I mean again Tiger
himself is a part of a grouping at
2-over par right now and that's just as
we're talking just six shots off the
lead who do you think
on a moving day on Saturday could push
pedal to the metal and really take this
masters over Brandon well I did I think
Rory you know Rory you know he made a
putt today on the second hole of 30
footer down the hill that broke it might
have broke 30 feet
it literally might have broke the putt
might have traveled 60 feet there was
only 30 feet to the hole he's making
more of these really difficult big
breaking 10 15 30 40 foot errs and
that's because of a lesson he had you
know just about a month or so ago with
one of the best putters ever Brad Faxon
and it freed him up and he went to the
Arnold Palmer Invitational had his best
putting week of his career he won the
event and it's like it turned him around
you know I think Justin Rose he was my
pick to win the tournament he's lurking
last time I looked it was two back maybe
three back but I still think Justin Rose
will win but I think Rory will be right
there I think couch will be there and I
think Spieth will be right there
was there any chatter within the Golf
Channel community about Sergio clapping
back at rich Lerner on Twitter where
we're rich said you know he didn't think
that Sergio was going to name his kid
fire horn because that's the name of the
15th hole right you know I mean I know
rich there's not a mean bone in rich as
rich as a buddy of mine is not a mean
bone he was it was making light of you
know something that everybody had said
you know I thought I thought he'd got a
little taken out of you know out of hand
it was like did its humor there was no
ill intent but yeah I'm sure it I'm sure
it caused rich a little angst last night
oh man your enemy he was like you've
been in a few Twitter rounds what do you
do here I was like well you know if you
feel like you're wrong apologize and
move on it wasn't the most egregious
thing ever
yeah he said I don't think he's gonna
named his kid fire horn and Sergio's
like well you know that's where I won my
championship last year so maybe I can
name my kid I mean I read that this
morning I'm like oh gosh because yeah
well Sergio's wife had a go at Rich last
night and he's not running oh yeah if
you go on and know that oh yeah she had
a go at him
and you know it started this big thread
and you know rich turns to me in the
middle of show and he said you know I
can't believe this I hadn't looked I
didn't know and I was like what did you
chew and he goes well I said okay I
don't it'll go away don't worry about it
but you know everything turns into a big
deal on Twitter just the slightest
implication of wrongdoing turns into a
big big Rao but it was distracting the
rich no well tow sent him our best we he
was on the show the other day I always
enjoy having him and you won't
appreciate the time
Brandon of course but y'all take care
have a great rest of the weekend that's
Brandel Chamblee analyst at golf central
right here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience